so the question is what exercise will
burn the most fat okay are the three
variables we have duration intensity and
recovery intensity is the factor that
will burn more fat than any other
exercise in fact intensity will increase
growth hormone by four hundred and fifty
percent so what I'm going to demonstrate
is a type of exercise called interval
training these kids gum high fructose
corn syrup this is this is going to kill
you
so I like to take the bike and you can
do Hills you can do sprints and then you
can relax because you can post with the
bike but when you do this you probably
don't want to start with a hill you want
to start with something a little bit
smaller
there are many exercises like you could
do for example you can do the skiing
exercise back and forth jumping back and
forth you can do pushing against the
wall trying to push the wall down you
can jump rope you can do push ups you
can jump up on up and down like burpees
but the main thing is to get high
intensity with some rest back and forth
but before you do this make sure you're
sleeping make sure you have enough
energy and make sure you're somewhat fit
and if you're just going into this you
might want to start off walking and then
doing it very very small and gradually
working yourself out but you want to
work up to this let's check it out
okay so that was called jump the stump
to get rid of your bump right so - my
wife always calls it alright so you can
take anything in your house you can do
stairs you can if you don't have a stump
you can use go to the gym you want to
find a little platform and you can hop
on things is called plyometrics so
basically the science of hopping but you
want to get your whole body every single
cell every single muscle in explosion
and we want to relax we're relaxing now
we're going to let our body fully come
down to a pre resting state for about
three minutes so you're going to do
high-intensity for maybe thirty seconds
and rest for three minutes
but each person is different you can
calculate your exercise recovery cycle
with different tests but we're not going
to get into that right now
so you're resting you're sitting here
you're waiting for your heart rate to
come down you're not jogging in place
you're sitting down but you want to
start off small you want to jump on
small little platforms to work up to
this don't just jump right up here right
away
but I have people in their 70s that are
doing this on their stairs of their
house so check out this guy right here
he's 75 years old he's jumping on his
stairs back and forth him and his wife
are doing it she's not in her seventies
she's in her 50s and they do this every
other day so it's very very healthy for
the cardiovascular system it's good for
your blood sugars and it's really good
for fat burning I want to take it to the
next level I want to see there's
something I could actually jump on that
it's a little higher than I normally
jump on I have an idea let's go over
here
should I do it should I try it Oh what
the heck you only live once there's one
more point about interval training to
keep growth hormone which is the anti
aging fat burning hormone continually
going up you have to keep making it more
difficult because your body adapts and
when your body gets used to it that
hormone doesn't increase anymore so you
have to constantly come up with creative
ideas to get make it harder and harder
so I'm kinda at the stage where I need
to come up with a really difficult jump
a really high jump let me think what I
can do I have an idea